deflected retrieved by Lou July finds
Aseema boy football with a little bit of
English off the window head man the
basketball right here you looking for
wild Leonard a nice little hesitation
oh there you see the line he has not
disappointed in his flipper debut here
is collage noodling shut up football a
sledgehammer follows let him operate in
this area of where he's very good nice
spin off spin I caught the spin cycle
and this dude is this date is so good
porzingis lost it again and this time
James controls it James in front we're
in intensity on that end that I've seen
in a long time
the ball comes loose yes he's is in a
great position with m2m missiles still a
bad man and his hit big Nullah coming
right at you
a little right back
fires
[Music]
James Hart blake capela eight straight
for houston this pass between hardens
legs approve a few possessions ago what
a great pass through his own five whole
through the pocket there to compel it
for the Duncan he's probably gonna spend
some time moving back and forth but Otto
Porter is out of the foot spray and dunk
it down how about that pass look at this
over the top pass capella is open so
hardens got to find a way to get giving
up the middle but he recovers and just
keeps his eye on it guys and lay it up
softly you got to attack with aggression
in this league though she's gonna see a
lot of your shots going the other
direction if you can flush it you should
the fresher LeBron this year and Sock'em
lays it in with the right hand
[Applause]
what a pass by lemon in another finish
inside we shoot 38%
[Applause]
the crowd wasn't quite as noisy there as
it was here I tell you that's some play
by LeBron James buzz lasted for about
half a minute like he said
Bogdanovich will take it out back to the
basket in a dribble alive that they did
then boy got tripped up and then ran
right into the wall
Anthony shot blocking leader Davis
number one in the NBA the verticality of
dammit
stumbling Barnes boy he just suffocated
him yeah he just really look how he just
it disappears in here begins all of the
length of Anthony Davis and the Lakers
they're the ones that escaped with a
wind is good with it tonight assist with
two shots
this is to pull up here is going
a person Lucan
birdy would be jealous as Luka finds
Dorian finney-smith that was perfect oh
my goodness several other time not an
easy path and Thompson and grant and all
those guys really nice passing Telegraph
that pass really in the corner oh you
gotta give Anthony Davis an assist was
something special the lead pass just tap
it and let me finish it but Braun says
and finish it he does the Lakers go up
94 79 else to give both on the penalty
under two to play harden step back puts
up the three got hit
James Harden double team got a chance
for a four-point play to their 8th
straight win and there
[Applause]
Davis gets here second block with
Anthony Davis on the floor nothing easy
in the paint and offensively but he
should be on the line especially
quotient plays like this where the lob
throws it up
[Applause]
heart drives dumps oh-ho baby could
another look at the drive and slam for
James Harden
[Music]
[Applause]
had nowhere to go there's another look
at that spinning booth hi ad
exim joe ingles ed Davis they all get a
piece of this one is showing the
footwork look he's got two guys on him
he knows he's got homes on himself
Capella's got to be open somewhere the
woodland Church supermo shows you what a
great pass over the shoulder that was to
compel us Bernard a 40% three-point
shooters roll back to a rolling Dwight
Powell that pass JC big and he really
lost until the world
another great Showtime feed from James
to Dwight we show place in a two-man
keep away Rajon Rondo will quarterback
[Music]
first stuff he does throws it down to
him be harder this season the Brawn of
his back to the basket once again kind
of forces where he hid behind the back
against aggravating scores another
behind the back time hunt the guy is
just remarkable as the Lakers go up by
four that's a three bonds at the combo
and it's picked up by LeBron down
[Applause]
sledgehammer at the other end out racing
out to the Combe ball here's the pass
break the pass why LeBron and the finish
over Yanis here for ad of the year
averages a little overtime per game
welcome dr. Londe serve it up at the fly
makers get that that signage goes
quickly chased out
the broad
the other timeout
bubble job of getting back and
preventing an easy deuce - then it does
a great job with the low dribble Danny
Green Showtime the good view Danny Green
throws it up there there's a couple
there's a guy there but Anthony Davis
over the top of bays and just flushes it
the assist he's got four helpers
LeBron's going to get the steal he
dreams Paris McHale all of all those
guys they were sitting on the bench
laughing whoo the blowout and that's
what the Lakers got to do a better job
of putting teams in well
[Music]
like a quarterback Brandon Ingram you
got boss
[Music]
it looks great
[Applause]
from Jackson open
[Applause]
with the rim rocking dunk and an
excellent look at it from our incredible
crew here in Dallas is Don Cheech works
the FAL banks it in
he'll have a chance for 3oz merits at
the end of the day you've given up 54
points with nine minutes ago in a second
you gotta find a way to shut your mouth
and begin to play with intensity James
this speed the force in the finish but
you see the difference but once you see
the spin of LeBron James it's no mess
around after that it's direct line drive
to the crop Leonard aggressive
[Applause]
the why has 34 an aggressive
the wide nose if he comes off a screen
they're double-teaming so turn down the
screen and go dunk on whoever's in the
paint that was a big-time play by
big-time player Brian and then heart
someone might need to give comments
extra hugs right here the quick jab
Brandon Knight from the initial
possession lost his footing and Kawhi
Leonard calibrated that move tandem is
there's been with the reversal in fame
whereas James get the beautiful pass he
gets around chemin Sonny Smith has his
three block bike alive my goodness hurry
for one and then blocks of shot and then
gets out and one dunk the basketball on
Luca Dante I mean what a couple plays
right there by Kawhi Leonard I mean nice
finish right there what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content